اهلا بك معنا سيد جبارين كيف تقرا تاثير
هذه الضربه في هذا التوقيت من الحرب ان
كان على المستوى السياسي او على مستوى
الشارع
الاسرائيلي نعم تحياتي استاذه سهام وصباح
الخير ربما قبل ذلك اسمح لي ان اعرج على
سؤالك لماذا تقوم اسرائيل بتفخيخ البيوت
اظن انك كنت قد سالت هذا السؤال بطبيعه
الحال يعني هذه احد الاستراتيجيات او على
على مستوى الجندي في المقام الاول هو يريد
ان يحصل على صوره بطوله يسوقها الى داخل
الشارع الاسرائيلي صوره بطوله واذلال الى
ما يعني الى المساحه الخاصه به اصدقائه
عائلته وهذا ما نراه في داخل السوشيال
ميديا بالمناسبه يعني فقط في الايام
الاخيره اين كيف يتم تداول ذلك مع موسيقى
واهداء وما الى ذلك الى هذا الحد ولكن
لماذا تسمح اسرائيل بذلك هذا السؤال الذي
يجب ان يسال في نهايه المطاف يعني هنا
الحديث عن الكثير من المتفجرات التي تقوم
بمثل هذا الحدث هنالك امرين اثنين تردهما
اسرائيل في المقام الاول اسرائيل يعني
تعلم جيدا بان ال يعني ال العقيده هي
عقيده عقيده الفلسطين مع الارض هي عقيده
وطن وارض وبالتالي هي تحاول اذلاله عبر
اذلال علاقته مع هذه الارض وبالتالي يتم
هدم هذه المنازل وهذه البيوت في المقام
الاول في في هذا الحد في هذا الحد سياسه
عقاب وتهجير جماعي كما نشهد ذلك في داخل
الضفه الغربيه بالمناسبه كذلك هذا الامر
يجب ان يخذ بعين اعتبار هذا على بالنسبه
لهذا السؤال اي تحديدا بالنسبه لتداعيات
هذا الحدث ربما هذا يذكر فقط بما انك بما
انك جئت على ذكر موضوع التفخيخ يعني فقط
لاسباب دعائيه
نفسيه يجري التعامل بهذا الشكل خصوصا ان
هناك اصلا جدل في اسرائيل حول جدوى هذه
المعارك لانها تخاطر بسلامه الجنود بينما
يمكن التركيز على الطيران الحربي اكثر في
الحرب يعني في نهايه المطاف هي صوره اذلال
يتم بثها يعني هذا يجب ان نتذكره لك ان
تتذكر الصور التي كانت ل
لجامعه الاقصى قبل اسابيع كيف تم تفخيخها
وتفجيرها جامعه الازهر عفوا فبالتالي واضح
جدا يعني هنالك نوع من الاذلال نوع من قصف
الرموز وهي تهدف في نهايه المطاف
الى يعني زرع في اللاوعي الفلسطيني بسياسه
الهجره لا تملك اي شيء لا يوجد لديك ملكيه
هنا ابعد اهجر حتى يعني في نهايه المطاف
هذا ما يحاول ان يقوله وزير الخارجيه في
يعني
تصريحه الغبي نوعا ما ان تقام جزيره
اصطناعيه لتاو الفلسطينيين اي هذا في
المقام الاول تحديدا في هذه الجزئيه في
الذاكره الجماعيه وعوده الى السؤال في
الذاكره الجماعيه الاسرائيليه عام 97 كان
هنالك يعني هذا الحدث يذكر الاسرائيليين
بحدث حادثه طائرات الهليكوبتر التي كانت
متجهه الى لبنان عام 97 التي ادت الى مقتل
تقريبا 73 جندي اسرائيلي انذاك وذلك الحدث
كان لديه الكثير من الزخم والوعي من جدوه
تواجد اسرائيل في جنوب لبنان الذي ادى في
نهايه المطاف وبعد سنتين تقريبا سنتين
ونصف تقريبا الى خروج اسرائيل من جنوب
لبنان طبعا في نهايه المطاف نحن نتحدث عن
مشهد في زمن يعني امد زمني طويل ذاك نحن
نتحدث عن 20 عام تواجدت بهم تقريبا 20 عام
تواجدت بهم اسرائيل في داخل جنوب لبنان في
اخر تراكميه المشهد في السنتين والنصف
الاخيره ادى هذا الحدث الى ان يصل الى ما
وصلت اليه بطبيعه الحال طبعا هنا الحدث
شبيه جدا في الوعي الاسرائيلي يعني
الاسرائيل تستطيع ان تتقبل اي شيء لكنها
لا تستطيع ان تتقبل عداد القتلى في صف
الجنود تستطيع ان تتقبل قصف الميركافا بدل
الواحده بالعشره والعشرون لكن عداد القتلى
في صف الجنود هو عدد لا تستطيع التعام مع
هذا في ما يتعلق ب بالحروب عموما ولكن هذه
الحرب تحديدا يروج لها على انها حرب
وجوديه حرب البقاء الثانيه وكل التصريحات
للمسؤولين الاسرائيليين تتجه في اتجاه
تبرير الثمن الباهظ الذي يجب ان يبذل من
اجل هذه الحرب بالتالي هل هذا المعيار
يسري ايضا على هذه
الحرب هذا صحيح ولكن هنالك نقطه مهمه جدا
يجب ان نتذكر ان لهذه الحرب هنالك تداعيات
اخرى في داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي الشارع
الاسرائيلي غير موحد في جبهه واحده في
الجبهه الداخليه في اسرائيل غير موحده
وبالتالي هذه هي الاشكاليه الكبرى الجبهه
الداخليه على الاقل وفق او الشارع
الاسرائيلي على الاقل وفق استطلاع للقناه
الث ع يوم امس
33% فقط يشدون بان نتنياهو يقوم بهذه
الحرب لمصلحه اسرائيل العامه 53% يشككون
باهدافه بل يقولون انها لاهدافه الشخصيه
53% من الشرع الاسرائيلي يرى ان جدوى هذه
الحرب هي فقط لانقاذ بنيامين نتنياهو وليس
لانقاذ اسرائيل وبالتالي مع هذا الامر
يتعامل الشعب الاسرائيلي تصريح الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اليوم يتحدث عن حرب لا يوجد
اعدل منها هل يتعلق الامر فعلا فقط
بحسابات
نتنياهو الان لكي نفهم ذلك بشكل اعمق
التحدي الحقيقي للشارع الاسرائيلي او
للاساس الاسرائيليون هو عندما يعود جنود
الاحتياط الذين بداوا يعودوا بطبيعه الحال
من داخل القطاع الى الشار الاسرائيلي
وهؤلاء نحن نتحدث عن الشريحه بين عمر ال
30 الى ال 50 ويجب ان نتذكر ما كانوا
يفعلون هؤلاء ما قبل السابع من اكتوبر
كانوا يقضون موجه الاحتجاجات في داخل
اسرائيل ا ذاك كانت موجه الاحتجاجات ذات
ابعاد سياسيه بحتى الان نحن نتحدث عن موجه
احتجاجات ذات ابعاد سياسيه وابعاد عسكريه
ان كل هذه العمليه هي فقط تؤدي الى مقتل
المزيد من الجنود لا تاتي بالاسرى بل تقتل
بالس تقتل الاسرى وبالتالي هؤلاء الصف هذا
جنود الاحتياط هؤلاء كانوا موجودون في
داخل هذه الجبهه يعرفون كل عايشوا و وكل
ال صور
ال الفشل التي يروها في داخل القطاع
بطبيعه الحال الاثر النفسي المتراكم عليهم
من كل ما شاهدوه في داخل القطاع يعودون مع
ذلك مع كل تراكميه ما كان ما قبل السابع
من اكتوبر يعني حتى بعيدا عن كل ما جر ما
بعد السابع من اكتوبر ما كان ما قبل
السابع من اكتوبر انا باعتقادي ان هذا
لوحده كفيل بان يحرك الشارع الاسرائيلي
بموجه تصاعديه كبيره هنا يجب ان نتذكر
ربما ونشير الى موجه احتجاجيه في اسرائيل
كانت ابان حرب 73 74 ضها شخص يسمى جندي
احتياط ان ذاك يسمى موتي اشكنازي و مصادفه
يوم امس كانوا يتحدثون بان الموجه التصعيد
التي تشهدها اسرائيل الان هي شبيهه
بالموجه التصعيد التي قاضه انذاك موت
اشكنازي في سنوات السبين انذاك في نهايه
تلك ال المرحله وفي نهايه تلك تلك
الاحتجاجات ادت اسرائيل ذهبت اسرائيل الى
انتخابات طبعا بعيد الحرب هذا الحديث كان
وبعدها بشهرين ومع ذلك مع اننا جولد مائير
وموشي ريان عادوا الى الحكم بعدها بشهرين
استقالوا كلاهما الاثنين الاشكاليه هنا
ويجب ان ناخذها بع الاعتبار ان جولد مائير
ليست نتنياهو جالانت ليس مرشدان الشارع
الاسرائيلي ليس بذات الرفاهيه التي كانت
انذاك مع اسرائيل
الوليده مصداقيه الحرب هي نست ذات الشرعيه
وذات المصداقيه وحتى المقاومه ليست نفس
مقاومه اليوم صحيح